yes I do work for the government I I
said this many times why are they
finding the need to go to Faris is he an
authority what connections does he have
to the
government just imagine the people back
in the day when they would have to
travel certain distances for months or
even yet what is one thing that they
would carry with them the Quran why
because they did not have it on their
mobile devices or their gadgets brothers
and sisters imagine you have a app the
Quran app which not only shows you how
much rewards you get but reminds you to
read the Quran gives you reminders
download the Quran app now and let it
testify for you on your that you read it
wherever you
was brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are in now in this
video brother and sisters there are
certain things that we need to
understand Piers Morgan and FIS hamadi
what do they both have in common well
some stuff and some not for example one
is it the outright disbeliever one you
can even categorize as an enemy of Islam
yes which is PS Morgan yeah for those
who might get confused like why would
somebody who has belief and IM where
Allah subh clearly tells in the Quran
that you should be soft towards the
belie Believers and harsh towards
disbelievers but you see the total
opposite of an individual you have to
ask a question why do they behave in
this manner now there are some couple of
things which we need to have into
context brother and sisters yeah and
Dani Haku has even I think written
something an article on this matter that
some of them I'm not saying all are
government agents they are SP
not only
that has even spoken about that that the
CIA they've have some connections with
the CIA they are known for this the
super super salafis I'm not put I myself
de myself as a salafy but I'm not
talking everyone I'm not putting
everyone in that category I'm talking
about the specific group who FIS sad
shami even sagit yes they all fit into
those category you work for the
government don't lie if you do it's okay
how would I lie and thank you I felt
kind of unsafe thank you for saying it's
okay yes I do work for the government I
I said this many times I work for irada
Center for rehab and treatment it's a
treatment center that is funded by the
government to help out drug addicts and
alcohol addicts to recover I'm not in
the medical team I work with policies
and procedures and kpis this is what I
do this is how I work for the government
and part time I work in Islamic
information center where where we help
out new Muslims and reverts uh to
understand Islam better if you think
that I'm like an evil agent that's
trying to implement and spread an evil
government agenda against Muslims in
Islam no I'm not that my contents is
there I don't like this is a very silly
conspiracy theory and an accusation and
here are some things I'm going to show
you which you're going to find
disturbing now this is from the year
2014 brothers and sisters yeah now let's
look at this very closely in 2014 Farris
hammadi wrote The Following 17
journalists gone down by Israel in Gaza
outcry about freedom of speech where is
freedom of speech now interesting that
doesn't sound like Paris but that was in
2014 Israel is a gangster a terrorist
State spot on this is the Faris nine or
nine years ago nearly a decade ago now
let's look at Pi Morgan Pi Morgan was
also very very similar very very similar
things what did he used to say he say
stuff like Israel is making a massive
mistake with this monstrous
child slaughtering military strategy
someone needs to Reign Netanyahu in fast
then he wrote what the hell is Israel
doing their third un School in Gaza
Shield shameful shameful a war crime RT
UNICEF at least 408 Palestinian children
killed as a result of air strikes and
shelling so it wasn't a ceasefire more
of a mutual reload predictable and
depressing where is the leadership to
stop this Insanity at what point does
Israel Israel's current military
strategy become the very terrorism it
possesses to be fighting this was both
in
2014 when I saw this I thought oh my
gosh this Pi changed his mind about
things and I realized it's the old peers
so is it the old FIS why is it that now
which I'm going to show you guys video
where Farris is outright claiming and
proud of saying that he works for the
government and there's nothing WR wrong
working for the government but the point
is this you can work for a government
that that's not a problem it doesn't
make you complicit of the good or the
bad that the government do in that
matter but for you to have a problem
where you cannot even say anything good
about Palestine you attack or indirectly
attack Hamas and only that you have it
so difficult to come out like you did in
2014 and to claim or even say that
Israel is a terrorist State why the
question is why now the head of Hamas
made a call to the jordanians or
something along those lines that you
guys are the sleep and giant so the
jordanians came to the streets yes um
they came to the streets um just you
know in protest or whatever yeah
somebody posted this check this out this
is from today's protest in Jordan many
many of these signs are filled with
curses towards Arab leaders okay it's
it's the Arab Spring all over again if
jordanians don't crush these bugs it
will go down may Allah protect Jordan
may Allah protect the king no problem
and this was liked by who Faris hmadi
not only that of course you have extreme
on the other side which uh there's an
individual who's wrot here that yeah he
says if you find that Scholars
frequently visit the house of the rulers
if you see a scholar sitting clapping
for the ruler then tell him oh scholar
they've turned you into a pillar pillar
on WS they rest the burden of their
oppression yes this was shared by
somebody now this person is wrong
because if I'm not mistaken
isan sitting on the right yeah so this
person was saying this guess what
happens you have an individual for some
odat reason if Faris is just working for
the government like he said in the video
that he's just you know somebody who
does you know helps people have
addiction Etc and works for the B Center
if it's just pertaining to that then why
is it that if you just work for the
government body what's wrong with you
speaking out against what Israel is
doing I'm sure there are many people who
live in the UAE who speak out against
atrocities that's being done I don't
think anyone's going to lock them up
they do speak about it so what's
stopping you at what level are you
working with the government yes are you
somebody who would go and go to the go
to the government off
call the police on the Believers yes
Brothers they do they are known to go to
the authorities over this matter now
here is something where somebody's for
some odd reason going to faradi out of
everybody and saying
what Mr Farris this is the S syian
foreign Ministry it talks about the
rulers and follows the foreign Ministry
Ahmed mus jibriel and even includes his
position in his account if it is if if I
report it to the UAE authorities will
they be able to obtain it it is
necessary to expel from it is necessary
to be expelled from this Noble country
God bless you why are they finding the
need to go to Faris is he an authority
what connections does he have to the
government what is it that they have to
go and ask him and in theha what they're
saying is they are literally going to
rat grass snitch on another believer
this person can be easily advised this
person can be spoken to to go and snitch
these individuals caused the people that
I've known who have been banned from
Saudi and been banned from certain UA
countries why because they go and they
snitch on these Muslims they lie about
them they snitch on them so the question
is what in a nutshell the question is
not what brother and sisters the
following Piers Morgan his matter is
clear he's a disbeliever yes he changed
his position probably got paid well or
his bosses at top told him to shut up
he's a disbeliever nobody's surprised
about him the question is the following
how is Farris so casually coming and
telling us oh but don't boycott casually
smoking and laughing about Starbucks
matters and here he seen that he is
clearly being people are coming to him
um asking him for advice about reporting
other Muslims to the authorities yes and
not only that he's making du against
group of jordanians coming out in
support of Palestinians yes some of them
may have held some signs whatever is for
that matter but that is the point here
we need to ask oursel a question this
man needs to be warned against we should
not fall for this same thing of just
somebody looks smirky you know MK nice
voice tone white beard don't fall for it
I'm not saying he's a very evil person
but there's a big question mark on him
and you need to be careful and do not
take from him because he said things
which are very very very
questionable for them to be sitting with
rulers does not necessarily mean they
are licking their backside or licking
their boots I'm so sorry I don't buy
that that's not wrong that is wrong they
could be advising them they could be
sincerely advising them there might be
other things that in place that is
stopping them you cannot outright make
them as bootlickers or oh they are
totally disregarded no I don't believe
that either I don't go to the Other
Extreme yeah we have to understand that
these rulers yes there are some
that against it for those that don't
does not mean they're sellout they're
doing it for the money you do not know
this is slander we do not know that
unless there is CL evidence I don't
believe in Rebellion I don't believe
that they should rebel against the ruler
but nor do I say those who speak out
against a ruler yes depends no one
talking about protest and coming out and
doing a revolution I'm not talking about
that I'm talking about those who speak
against it and talks about the evil that
they do Etc that does not make him a
doesn't make okay um and the point is
what I believe that there is more harm
than good to come if you rule if you go
against the ruler I understand that
there is whole there's a whole
understanding behind it I'm not going to
the nitty-gritty I know that I believe
there's more harm than good when you
rebel against a ruler but neither do I
go to the Other Extreme of yeah anything
that they say it's as if you worship
them no and in matters where it's
clearcut Stu pertaining to that's all I
want to say may Allah guide him and
myself